il envoie sa droite BIM BIM hop je
l'attrappe je le jette et je m'en vais
le temps qui se relève j'ai déjà gagné
du temps comment réagir lors d'une
agression le selfdfense apporte quelques
réponses pour avoir les bons réflexes
dans ce type de situation toujours
difficile l'effet de surprise est tel
que on a aucun réflexe et donc c'est ça
qui est bien c'est que là on apprend à
avoir des réflexes en cas de besoin
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez appris
jusque là alors les petits coups faciles
à faire où on a pas besoin de beaucoup
de force pour faire mal et se donner le
temps de partir à fond la caisse aider
un maximum de personnes à pouvoir avoir
le réflexe de mettre un doigt dans l'œil
de mettre un coup dans la gorge de
mettre un coup dans les parties
génitales de pincer de crier de s'en
sortir avec les éléments qu'on a sur soi
à ce moment-là les participants de ce
stage organisé à boisarc apprennent à se
défendre sur des saisies par de simples
pressions sur les endroits sensibles du
corps humain et la réaction est
automatique faut le maîtriser en fait on
le maîtrise pas encore donc à force de
s'exercer on va le maîtriser par la
suite et je pense que c'est efficace au
programme également la découverte du
kickboxing la boxe piedpo une discipline
complémentaire du Penchak Sila fait le
kickboxing sport de percussion donc
c'est on va apprendre à donner des coups
des des coups de point des coups de
pieds on va apprendre à enchaîner les
les coups de pieds et coup de point et
la self défense va venir en
complémentarité où on va essayer de
neutraliser la personne en cas
d'agression pour soit opter pour la
fuite soit la mettre par terre et si
vous avez un problème de G demander au
jeunes prochain stage le 16 février à
voisin
lebreteneux